what's happening right now I'm standing
at my door oh you are a pretty cool door
we're gonna go to over there I'm gonna
give pixel away and it's going to tip in
case we are getting pixel still have a
big fear snakes
oh maybe like my dream come true if I
couldn't have a dog
then at least I get to have a snake so
we are adopting pixel and so we're gonna
set up pixel right here in this area
where the TV used to be I think never
uses this room honestly it's like a it's
our spare room because Isaac always
sleeps in our bed and Casey and I we
we've been sleeping in the couch
recently we don't even use our own
bedroom so this room is just a spare
room but eventually we're gonna try to
fix up this room make it cool for Isaac
so he you can start using his own room
we have we just rearranged everything
we're gonna start cleaning this thing
down and bringing our new baby pixely
guys like man one was pixel yeah we got
a new baby all settled in so exciting
I'm so happy to finally be just being
pixels foster parents for now until Gina
decides like hey I want my baby back
baby back baby back baby okay I think
now it's my moment of truth we need to
introduce pixel up to our furry babies
another one yeah sure now don't get too
close just in case you know you never
know but pixel is from the camera angle
looks like they're really close to each
other is actually pretty much like
everyone from you you look bad I had
become so you feel that now you're a
snake owner I don't do anything okay my
acne picks me pick some - oh sweet lady
- the hell are you eating each other so
today we are going to bar first rat to
feed pixel with this is two days in of
us owning pixel and yeah I'm actually
kind of nervous now can stead pixel
before and I've watched and pixel
snatches our rat so fast it's like it's
kind of intimidating so we'll see how it
goes and then even just looking at a
dead rat that that body is kind of just
all right we go let's do it medium they
look so cute it's four six foot snake so
I don't know how this one that looks
about right actually do that oh okay you
guys want to watch or oh you want to
only want to watch how much oh man I
think you're crazy
I can't he's a crazy boy um you get
somebody good I don't yeah I know what
to do it I can't do it I can't do it
he's just these food okay just think of
them as food is food for pixel food for
pixel he's gonna do it all right go for
it you're the man horny due to graphic
content viewer discussion is advised
the deed is done
$3.99 life is cheap the deed is done it
is oh my god even the dude didn't want
to kill them he's like let me find some
video but then I guess can't find
anybody so now we're on our way back
home
we're gonna be feeding pixels we sould
finish the rest of the day and I gotta
go I have a parent-teacher conference in
like 30 minutes oh yeah do that we're
gonna meet with Isaac's teacher excited
for that have you been good or bad at
school yeah I think you've been good too
alright we're home all right you ready
Isaac happy day for a fix was a happy
day it's feeding day she gets to eat you
got it baby how you feeling right now
okay
well I'm a man I should do it
alright I'll do it next time but I want
to do it because one it's ultimately her
idea to bring pixel into her household
will share the deed will share it you
wanted you wanted pixel it's not that
easy it's a little screwy fixing her
hungry oh there she she's moving she's
on the prowl she's not eating it
so we just got back from the
parent-teacher conference so it only
took like 20 minutes that bad but in
that time and we couldn't sit around and
wait for pixelate your food which by the
way I hit up Gina I'm like hey Gina like
she's actually takes a long time to eat
her food like what's up and then I told
her that I had just dropped the rat in
the tank
she's like no pixel doesn't need like
that pixel likes to eat like she likes
to hunt her food but she doesn't like to
give her a lie Brett because she doesn't
want pixel to get scratched with the
rats claws or anything so what Gina
usually does and can what they usually
do is they'll kill the the rat and then
kind of wave it in front of pixels face
and then that's when she'll go she'll
attack which is something I didn't do so
now that we got home we can I just had
to leave pixel because we were in a rush
for the parent-teacher conference but
now getting home we see the aftermath
all the rats blood and the reason why
there's water in here is because I
sprayed the tank because her tank needs
to be humid but Pixel finished eating
with us being gone so but next week now
we know what to do to properly feed her
which is to wave around the dead rat in
front of her face which I will not be
doing this guy will be doing it's a
murder scene in here but I mean it's
meant to be food the bus not bad
it's like your nosebleed it's like you
have cut me just wipe it out also the
the bloody Ness isn't bad because you're
just saying is just like a nosebleed
yeah